لا تقلق يا بوتين فنحن ايضا نستطيع اللعب
كبار هكذا قالتها بلد المليون ونصف
المليون شهيد من خلف الكواليس للدب الروسي
هنا الصين وروسيا تطمئنان الجزائر
مقعدكم موجود وسط الكبار ولكن في الوقت
المناسب فصدق او لا تصدق استبعاد الجزائر
من مجموعه بريكس كان مفاجاه للجميع ما عدا
الحكومه الجزائريه نفسها الامر ليس كما
يبدو في الظاهر يا عزيزي نحن لا نجامل ولا
نهول فليبوتين جنود وحلفاء النيران
والانقلابات المتسارعه تشتعل في افريقيا
فرنسا تحمل عفشها مطروده من افريقيا لتحل
محلهم القوات الروسيه مدعومه بفاقنار
الجزائري لم تنسى ما صنعته فرنسا ليحل
القضاء في افريقيا وكما يق المصريون متغور
بريكس انا عايز اخد بيطاري نعم هكذا استغل
بوتين الجزائر وتقربها من دول افريقيا ففي
كل انقلاب حدث في افريقيا كانت رائحه
الجزائر تفوح منه فكل الانقلابات التي
حدثت في افريقيا كانت تهدف الى قطع اليد
الفرنسيه ما هي الاسباب الخفيه لعدم قبول
انضمام الجزائر لمجموعه بريكس ولماذا وافق
بوتين على استبعاد جنديه المجهول من
الجلوس بجانبه امام الكاميرات وهل الامر
عباره عن سياسه دول كبرى الجزائر طرف فيها
في الخفاء لتعرف اجابه كل تلك الاسئله
تابع الفيديو للنهايه
غضب في الظاهر وضحكات خلف الكواليس اليوم
الرابع والعشرون من اغسطس الماضي قاده
بريكسي يجتمعون في جوهانس للاعلان عن
الاعضاء الجدد الكل يترقب في قلق وجندي
بوتين المجهول وحليفه الوثيق في افريقيا
كان يعلم بالنتيجه قبل اعلانها ونقصد
الجزائر ليعلن رئيس المجموعه
عن قبول الارجنتين ومصر واثيوبيا وايران
والسعوديه والامارات لنضع خطا تحت اثيوبيا
فماذا لو تمعن قليلا فوضعها الاقتصادي ليس
افضل من الجزائر فالجزائر الان باتت دوله
بلاديون ناهيك عن بحار النفطي والطاقه
التي تسمح فيه ونهضتها الاقتصاديه التي
جعلتها احدى اكثر دول العالم طموحا حتى
انها عرضت دعم بنك بريكس بمبلغ قدره
مليارا ونصف المليار دولار الخبر كان
صادما للجميع والكل تساءل في عجاب يا الهي
اين الجزائر اين محارب الصحراء والدوله
الطموحه وما زالوا علمت انه رغم صدمه
الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا في استبعاد الجزائر
ولكن لم ينصدم الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد
تبون نعم تلك هي الحقيقه فالكثير من
المحللين يرون ان الجزائر كانت على علم
بكل شيء قبل الاجتماع بدليل انه في الوقت
الذي قامت فيه كل الدول بالتمثيل على اعلى
مستوى وارسلت رئيس وزرائها واخرى حضر رئيس
البلاد بنفسه واخرى حضر باغلب اعضاء
حكومته اما الجزائر لم ترسل الا ممثلا
واحدا لها فقط وهو وزير ماليتها وكان الدب
الروسي تعلمون كل شيء لترد الجزائر نعم
نعلم ونحن ماضون على اتفاقنا انها سياسه
الكبار يا عزيزي فماذا حدث خلف الكواليس
الاحتفاظ بالكرت الرابع
دعني اقول لك ان الجزائر لم تستبعد من
الانضمام لبريكس اصلا بل فقط تم تاجيل
قبولها وكل التوقعات تشير الى انها ستنضم
للمجموعه العام القادم مساله وقت لا اكثر
خصوصا وان وزير الخارجيه الروسيس صرح
قائلا كل الشروط بريكس تنطبق على الجزائر
فهي دوله ذات ثقل سياسيا وهيبه دوليه
كبيره وقبولها قد يتم في العام القادم
فبوتن يرى ان انضمام الجزائر للمجموعه
الان سيحرق ورقته الرابحه وستتركز اعين
الغرب وبلاد العم سام على مخالب الدب
الروسي في افريقيا ففي اقوى صفعه وجهها
بوتين للغرب ونقصد هنا انقلاب النيجر كانت
الجزائر حاضره بقوه ونفوذها كانت هي اول
دوله تفتتح معها النيجر حدودها في اشد
الاوقات حساسيه وصعوبه ولو تمعن في الجانب
العسكري سنجد ان روسيا قد اعطت الدائره
كما كبيرا من الاسلحه التكتيكيه والغواصات
الاستراتيجيه من بينها غواصه الثقب الاسود
وزد عليها
والتي لم تعطيها لاي دوله او حليف اخر
وكان لسان حال بوتين يقول من الافضل تاجيل
انضمام الجزائر الى
ابعادها عن الشبهات وجعلها كالجندي
المجهول الذي يحرك اوراق اللعب في الساحه
الافريقيه فلا يزال امامنا الكثير من
المهام الصعبه في القاره السمراء التي يجب
ان تتم في الظل بعيدا عن الاعين ولن
يستطيع احد القيام بها الا محارب الصحراء
يبدو ان دور الجزائر القادم في افريقيا
سيكون اكبر بكثير مما يتوقع الجميع ولكن
في نفس الوقت كان لابد من الاجابه علنا
على اللغز المحير لماذا تم رفض انضمام
الجزائر وهي افضل اقتصاديا من اغلب الدول
الجديده التي تم وعلى راسها اثيوبيا
الاسباب المعلنه كان تاجيل حسم ملف
الجزائر هو اكثر الامور اثاره للجدل في
هذا الاجتماع اما عن الاسباب المعلنه
فبحسب صحيفه الانديبانت البريطانيه لعبت
الهند والبرازيل دورا رئيسيا في تاجيل
قبول الملف الجزائري مرجعين ذلك الى بعض
المعايير الاقتصاديه المطلوبه تواجدها في
الدول المنضمه للمجموعه وليست متوفره في
الاقتصاد الجزائري بالوقت الحالي
فالدولتان طريان ان الاقتصاد الجزائري وان
كان يشهد نهضه عظيمه في الوقت الحالي الا
انه ليس اقتصادا متنوعا ويعتمد في الاساس
على عوائد النفط والطاقه فقط لذا فان
الدوله الافريقيه طموح بحاجه الى تنويع
مصادر دخلها والقيام باصلاحات اقتصاديه
خصوصا في القطاع المصرفي وحسب خبير
الاقتصاد الجزائري الدكتور احمد طرطار ف
اهم اسباب رفض دعوه بلاده للانضمام لبريكس
كانت محدوديه نصيب الفرد من اجمالي الدخل
الوطني وضعف النظام المصرفي الجزائري
مقارنه بالنظام المصرفي العالمي وضعف قطاع
النقل الجوي والبحري وعدم قدره الموانئ
الجويه والبحريه على استيعاب تدفق
المسافرين والسلع والخدمات واعتماد
الاقتصاد بشكل شبه كلي على النفط والطاقه
فقط ولكن رغم ان اسباب الرفض المعلنه كلها
اسباب اقتصاديه الا ان هناك من يرى
وبالدلائل ان المعيار الاقتصادي ليس هو
السبب الحقيقي في تاجيل قبول ملف الجزائر
الدكتور عبد الرزاق غراف الباحث بمركز
ابحاث الخليج بالسعوديه انتقد المعيار
الاقتصادي كسبب حقيقي لرفض الجزائر قائلا
رغم ان هذا المعيار غير متوفر في الاقتصاد
الجزائري الذي تسيطر الهيدروكربونات على
صادراته باكثر من 90 بالمئه ف هناك من
اقتصادات الاعضاء الجدد من هم اقرب الى
حاله الجزائر فضلا على ان هناك من نقاط
الجذب الاقتصاديه التي يتوفر عليها الملف
والجزائر مثل مستوى المديونيه شديد
الانخفاض والذي لا يتعدى 30 مليار دولار
مقارنه بالارجنتين التي تناهز مديونيتها
382 مليار دولار واجمالي الناتج المحلي
الجزائري الذي يناهز 190 مليار دولار
مقارنه باثيوبيا التي لا يتجاوز ناتجها
المحلي 130 مليار دولار اي انه اذا كان
المعيار الاقتصادي هو المعيار الحقيقي
الذي يتم على اساسه قبول او رفض ملف
الدوله فان الارقام هنا في صالح الجزائر
والتي تتفوق في هذا المعيار بكثير على دول
اخرى تم قبولها كالارجنتين واثيوبيا ايفا
فان كنتم تتذرعون بالمعيار الاقتصادي
فالجزائر كانت اولى وال هي من يتحدث وهي
خير دليل ولكن يبدو يا عزيزي ان للامر
حسابات اخرى اكثر تعقيدا مما يبدو وان
اللعبه السياسيه كانت تتطلب رفضا ملف
الجزائر الان ليتم قبوله في الوقت المناسب
هكذا يلعب الكبار السؤال الان لكم
مشاهدينا هل حقا تم رفض الجزائر بسبب
المعايير الاقتصاديه كما اعلن ام ان الدب
الروسيه ومحارب الصحراء مقبلون على حفله
الانتقام لن نستعجل فالايام المقبله هي من
ستخبرنا بذلك ننتظر تعليقات منكم لتخبرون
برايكم
[موسيقى]